let's be honest we probably all know
someone who uses e-cigarettes
even though it's illegal to buy or sell
Vapes to anybody under 18 thousands of
us have been tempted to try them out my
friends they'll be doing it in school
and the toilets and stuff like that and
they can't go a day without doing it
well my first impressions is very very
colorful I mean we could be in a Sweet
Shop here couldn't we I know that plenty
of was a vape in so I want to know if
these things are harming our health
God didn't give us lungs to inhale a lot
of hot chemicals and expect to get away
with it Vapes also contain nicotine so
nicotine is extremely addictive
I'm gonna be hearing from a former Vapor
who when he was 16 went through a really
scary experience
I got given 20 chance to live and they
didn't think I was going to make it
through the night and I'll be taking my
findings to The Vaping industry young
people are going to experiment with
adult products and this is why we're
looking at ways of how do we minimize
young people's access to these products
wherever you go these days chances are
you'll spot people puffing on
e-cigarettes and clouds of vapor hanging
in the sky
if you haven't seen a vape before this
is what one looks like and when you
bring it up to your mouth a battery
warms up the liquid inside which is then
turned into vapor made up of tiny
particles which you can then breathe
into your lungs or blow out into the air
they're quite expensive and they're
meant to be just for adults but somehow
increasing numbers of Vapes have been
finding their way into schools but is it
a big deal
well I'm gonna talk to some year eight
pupils they have permission from their
teachers and parents but just for their
welfare we're not going to show their
faces
there's not many ways to stop it because
it's just everywhere
even when you walk through a town it's
impossible to go five minutes without
seeing several people vaping
the feather young years are doing it as
well it's just horrific people pressure
you to actually do it even though you're
young and you shouldn't be doing that
yourself
people just lock themselves in a cubicle
and start vaping with their friends it's
ridiculous the smoke that they exhale
you can inhale which means you are
getting some of them drugs into you
people tend to steal them off parents
siblings and sell them all around the
school
okay so here's the thing I've never vote
myself but I know that some of my mates
have even though they're not supposed to
I'm not grassing them up for anything
but the truth is that more and more of
us are giving it a try and here's the
evidence
I've done a search and there are loads
of studies on how many of us are vaping
but I'm gonna go with this one because
it's from the National Health Service
they've been monitoring how many
Secondary School pupils have been using
e-cigarettes
back in 2018 six percent of 11 to 15
year olds were using Vapes but according
to the most recent figures that's gone
up to nine percent which works out at
nearly half a million of us and the
older we get the more likely we are to
take up vaping by the time we're 15 14
of boys and 21 of girls are using Vapes
so why has vaping become so popular well
I've managed to get a hold of some 16
and 17 year olds who are regular Vapors
we're protecting their identities but
they have permission from their parents
to talk to me
so how old were you when you first
started vaping I was 12 in year eight so
about like 13 years old I was 15.
basically all of my friends did it so I
just hung around with them so much that
I was like why not what made you like
really want to start would you influence
Baby by your friends your family the
main reason why I Vape it's not the
feeling it's not the flavor it's the
tricks that's what you see on social
media as well so when you say tricks you
mean like making shapes with it with the
smoke yeah yeah it's almost like I'm
doing it to look cool
and no one admits that but I will it's
to look cool that's what all the kids
are doing it for how do you get hold of
them because obviously you're not 18 how
do you get hold of The Vape products so
there are some shops that do sell to
under 18s and I get them off quite a lot
of my friends like my friends they'll be
doing it in school and the toilets and
stuff like that and they can't go a day
without doing it would you say that
you're addicted do you do it a lot yeah
I definitely say I'm addicted like I go
for like two or three a week like
every two or three days I have to buy
another one and everything so I do spend
quite a lot of money on it as well like
say they're like six seven pounds of ape
so if you go three or four of them a
week that's that's quite a lot of money
and then like you're basically paying to
have problems with your body obviously
but it's kind of hard to get off it when
like all your friends are doing it you
just don't want to be the other one out
does it worry you maybe that it could
have a health impact in the future you
get to hold so many things from
different people like my one of my good
friends who's 18 she stopped vaping
and then she got an after effect from
the stopping it she got gum disease from
stopping vaping and then other people
were telling me like the man that serves
me in a shop he tells me that there's no
problem with vaping so you get really
mixed signals and I guess I'm just not
just paying much attention to the bad
side as much as I should I looked into
that thing about gum disease and
a bit confusing some studies say that
vaping can cause gum disease but others
say it doesn't it's pretty clear that
there's more research needed to be done
on that I did see that it does affect
health and I don't do it as much as I
did but I was never really bothered by
it because I'm young and I was like I
only live once so like just do whatever
do you think that more needs to be done
to help protect young people 100 what I
find a bit weird is that on cigarette
packets they have the photos the
warnings telling you to stop
put in Vape ones they don't and if it's
such a big deal when all these problems
are happening why are they not putting a
photo warning on on Vapes
so what I really want to know is whether
there are any health risks with vaping
the NHS says Vape in is much less
harmful than smoking cigarettes full of
tobacco which released really harmful
chemicals into your lungs
the whole idea of vaping was to get
adults to quit cigarettes but the NHS
says just like cigarettes most Vapes
contain highly addictive nicotine so a
lot of people struggle to give them up
and vaping isn't completely risk-free
to try and get some more info I've
arranged to meet someone who's looking
into their health risks
this is King's College in London
and they've got a whole team of people
working on it right now
[Music]
I'm meeting Eve Taylor who is one of the
researchers so how does this study that
you're doing actually work so for this
current study we're asking young people
aged 16 to 19 to fill out a
questionnaire and then also to send in a
urine sample and then with this urine
sample we can see what kind of chemicals
young people are being exposed to from
vaping and smoking but then also compare
them to people that are doing neither so
what will you learn from these urine
samples from teenagers so we already
know roughly from adult surveys the
types of chemicals that people are
exposed to from vaping
however we don't know if this might be
slightly different among young people
because young people Vape slightly
differently so they tend to vape
slightly different products and what do
we already know about the safety of
vaping so what we know is it's
significantly less harmful than smoking
however there is still some exposure to
certain chemicals Vapes also contain
nicotine so nicotine is extremely
addictive and we don't want people who
aren't smoking to start consuming
nicotine because as it's extremely
addictive you can start experiencing
Cravings withdrawals and it's then very
hard to stop vaping so sounds like it's
going to take a while before there's
reliable evidence about the long-term
Health impacts of vaping but I've been
told that many doctors who work with
children are already concerned like the
top guy here at the Royal Brompton and
harefield Hospital Professor Andrew
Bosch
I'm quite excited about this chat
because he's one of the UK's leading
consultants for children
[Music]
do you think teenagers our age should be
concerned about vaping they certainly
should there are major health problems
including nicotine addiction so if you
start vaping
there is a risk a small risk but a
definite risk that you can get a very
serious lung disease people have gone
into intensive care units gone heart
bypass machines because of acute
exposure to vaping you know some people
I know they Vape but they're not 100
sure what it does to you in the long
term could you please explain what some
of those risks may be in the long term
we just don't know it's an unknown it
took 30 years to prove that smoking
cigarettes cause lung cancer we don't
want to sit on our hands while another
Fiasco like that develops you know God
didn't give us lungs to inhale all of
hot chemicals into them and expect to
get away with it
even though more research is needed on
vaping I found out there's been a big
warning from an agency that's
responsible for everyone's Health on the
planet
the World Health Organization says
vaping products are harmful and aren't
safe
take a look at this video they made it's
pretty scary stuff E-cigarettes are
particularly risky when used by children
and adolescents exposure of Children and
adolescents to nicotine a highly
addictive substance can have long
lasting and damaging effects on the
developing brain
they go on to say vaping can potentially
lead to learning and anxiety disorders
[Music]
when I was reading up on the internet
looking for anyone who'd been badly
affected by vaping I came across this
guy in Nottingham he looks pretty
healthy right but back in 2017 he was a
regular vapor it's becoming a big big
thing nowadays and I'd say just please
don't do it mostly for your family and
yourself because you've got to worry
about all the dangers that come with it
because I wouldn't wish what happened to
me upon anyone
the night before his GCSE exams
um found himself in hospital
he was 16 and his lungs were failing
because of a bad reaction to his vaping
you might find his story a bit upsetting
so what happened when you were taken
into Hospital let's say when I got put
into mind youth coma my family got told
to come into the hospital because they
had to say the goodbyes to me really
because I got given 20 chance to live
and they didn't think I was going to
make it through the night at one stage
which was very very frightening for them
obviously it must have been horrible for
them imagine being told that someone in
your family is going to die especially
your son like for my mum and dad and
when you look back at photographs now is
it really difficult for you yeah it's
really hard actually my mum made me this
book of all the photographs um like from
what happened when I was in hospital
that was when I was at my worst time and
I was literally dying and so it's hard
to look back on
um especially photos like that with a
big tube in my neck that was like the
worst time of my life I couldn't think
of anything worse I mean I can't imagine
how that situation must have been it
must have been so difficult for you and
how are you now if you made a full
recovery I'd say around 80 but I've
still got a lot of problems I still get
a lot of joint problems and my lungs
aren't back to full capacity which there
was before
[Music]
companies
are sizing for e-cigarettes
but are they finding clever ways to get
around those rules
well the production team bought some of
the most popular vaping products from
the internet and loads of shops
take a look at them all
and helping me to check them out is
Chris arning a branding and marketing
expert so what are your first
impressions well Braden um my first
impressions is we've stumbled into a
sweet shop here
um these are all quite bright aren't
they we're going to call lurid pinks and
kind of Reds and yellows very bright
very vibrant the sort of thing that I
can imagine seeing in a in a sweet aisle
somewhere in a corner shop or a
supermarket literally I mean there's so
many different colors and it almost like
jumps out at you yeah and if we look at
some of the flavors let's go for this
one first yeah this is gummy bear I mean
it's crazy really that isn't it just
look at that very interesting the
language they're using here and
certainly I'm thinking there's
definitely an appeal to to younger
people definitely and I'm sorry I'll
have I'll have to owe you this
that is I have to say I'm a bit shocked
at that that that is very very close in
the visuals to a very a sort of quite a
famous chewy Sweet brand I think we all
know so yeah I'm pretty pretty surprised
at that actually
obviously there there were there were
this sort of statutory government
warning appears here but as with other
researchers shown here this is
necessarily what people focus on when
they see the pack this is definitely
conveying harmless sweet fun to be
indulged
but our vaping companies actually doing
anything wrong
well I've worked out that it's the job
if the advertising standards authority
to make sure that all advertising sticks
to the rules they're based in this
building but guess what they don't want
to talk to me instead they sent us this
email
it is not our view that advertising is
the central cause of the uptake in
vaping by young people we have not seen
evidence that firms are targeting young
people through advertising
they must have their eyes shut and think
the world is flat if they believe that
it may be true they're they're not
deliberately using classic advertising
to Target young people but all you need
to do is look at this packaging the
color the vibrancy the Striking
similarity to sweets and even toys and
other sort of products that appeal to
kids and you can see I would say it's a
bit naive to suggest that these packages
are not influencing young people to want
to try these products it should be plain
packaging there should be no flavored
chemicals in these e-cigarettes if
you're trying to give up smoking why on
Earth do you need a mango flavored
liquid I mean give me a break it's a
nonsense I think it is definitely aimed
at a younger generation because other
adults really care about having like
rainbow colors on their Vapes and like
jungle flavored Vapes and all that to be
honest it's not the adult eye that
catches the colors it's the kids it's on
the other either wants the blueberry and
the sweet flavors it's the kids
I'm kind of disappointed that the
advertising standards Authority wouldn't
talk to me because I had loads of
questions for him
like check this out as a football fan
I've noticed that vaping companies have
even started advertising on the shirts
of sports teams like Blackburn Rovers I
mean I just can't get my head around
that because football is meant to be all
about healthy living and keeping fit but
loads of kids will be seeing their
favorite players with a vaping brand
across the shirt
we contacted Blackburn Rovers and they
sent us a statement it said we have seen
no evidence to suggest that our
sponsorship has seen an uptake of vaping
among children we acknowledge we have a
responsibility to encourage Healthy Life
Choices for Children and we do not see
that raising awareness of the positive
role that vaping plays in helping to
eradicate smoking among adults conflicts
with this in any way
it seems very strange to me that lots of
other countries including China India
and Brazil are cracking down on
e-cigarettes while here in the UK that's
not the case in fact according to
trading standards an organization that's
designed to protect Shoppers one in
three businesses selling Vapes or
ignoring the law that's supposed to
prevent children from being able to buy
them and some of the Vapes they're
selling contain illegally high levels of
nicotine
so I'm gonna try and get some answers
from the body that represents the UK
vaping industry which is worth more than
a billion pounds a year
so we know that a lot more people my age
have started to vape recently is that a
concern for you absolutely it's a big
concern for us you have uh you know Road
Traders out there that frankly don't
care who they sell products to some of
the recommendations we've actually made
to government is that they should
increase the fines for retailers who are
caught selling products to miners and we
think that stores that sell these
products should be licensed because when
I go out on the street you know I can
see them in newsagents I can see them in
pizza shops and hairdressers these
Outlets are really not familiar with how
to sell these products so the World
Health Organization have said that
vaping is harmful to our health and
isn't safe and that vaping has long-term
consequences on brain development in
young people have they got that wrong I
think they have some of the things that
I see coming out of the World Health
Organization when I look at the science
that's available it doesn't make sense
but what we do know that is if you smoke
you're probably a one and two chance
that you'll die from smoking and 220
people die every day from smoking
related diseases in the UK
so switching to something that's less
harmful for you that's not 100 safe and
nobody is saying that it's 100 safe
um is a far better thing for you to do
if you can't quit any other way well
that's interesting so we've got the UK
vaping industry spokesman saying the
World Health Organization have got it
wrong about the health risks it really
sounds like we need more independent
research to get to the bottom of this so
if we move on to the packaging in the
advertising do you accept that young
people are attracted to the big colors
and the flavors but I think there's a
lot of adult products out there that
that use color that use flavor and I'm
probably a great example I'm in my
mid-50s and my big bug bear at the
moment is I love Cola bottles and Haribo
you know so adults do like flavors that
could be considered youth appealing as
well
so I've got a few examples here in my
pocket do you accept that these might be
appealing to children or to young people
well first of all this one would
technically be illegal you know the
biggest issue is going to be the naming
of it
um and the fact that it's got Skittles
on there that's not allowed under the
regulations currently so I know that
there are trading standards officers
that will pull that product off the
shelf and and confiscated you know we've
worked with certain brands that are very
popular here in the UK and we've
encouraged them to maybe tone down some
of the packaging that they're using
because we're a trade body and we don't
have any enforcement Powers we really
are reliant on the government to look at
the current regulations and put some
sensible changes in place that we've
suggested that would solve a lot of the
problem
having heard all this I want to go back
and see the guys I spoke to earlier
about their vaping
will it persuade them to quit I am
pretty scared and I probably could try
and give it a go like to stop vaping but
all try and cut down definitely because
like the way I go through Vapes is
definitely quite dangerous I won't lie I
think more people should breathe fresh
air because the vaping like there's
really no need for it shops kinda need
to sort out selling to under 18s and
stuff like that because I don't think
it's good so do you think that needs to
be stricter rules yeah definitely I do
worry about it a little bit because like
it could be really really bad and in a
couple years I could be in a hospital
somewhere because of it I'm sure I'm
going to look back on it when I'm older
probably when I'm out of my teens I'll
be like why was I even doing that but I
feel like that's a big part of growing
up you do things you're not supposed to
do this is clearly one of them
[Music]
when I started this investigation I
really wasn't sure what I'd discover and
it's become clear that there are two
sides to this story
on the one hand I get that Vapes have
helped many adults quit smoking tobacco
cigarettes which are far more dangerous
than Vapes
but on the other hand it's pretty clear
that lots of people my age are taking up
vaping and there really are concerns
about the damage that it could be doing
to our health
plus we found out that even The Vaping
industry wants there to be stronger
rules to stop Vapes being sold to
children and they want the government to
take action we approached the Secretary
of State for health unfortunately he
wouldn't talk to me about this
instead we were sent a statement from
the government's Department of Health
and Social care it said we are clear
that children should not use Vapes and
have introduced regulations to prevent
them from vaping adverts for Vapes are
prohibited from featuring anything
likely to be of particular appeal to
people under the age of 18.
from what we found out during this
program it appears those policies aren't
working the regulations aren't
preventing people my age getting hold of
Vapes and the teenagers we've spoken to
have told us they do find the colorful
branding and sweet flavors of the boat
products appealing so we're going to
send this program to the prime minister
so he can see what we found out as well
as the first Ministers of Scotland and
Wales
and we'll be asking them if more needs
to be done to warn young people about
the dangers of vaping and to crack down
on the many shops that are selling Vapes
to kids
[Music]
foreign